the average baby will go through over 3
000
diapers in a single year at around 70 to
80
a month the cost of these diapers will
set a family back nearly 1 000
a year and right now this essential is
getting more expensive for millions of
americans
in march diaper manufacturer kimberly
clark announced that it would be raising
prices on many of its products
including diapers and then competitor
procter and gamble
announced it would be doing the same for
families with multiple children
these price hikes could add up to
hundreds of dollars more per year
these price increases are happening on
household goods on food on gas
not only is it an amount that adds up
it's an amount that comes in addition to
everything
else costing more so what's causing
diaper prices to rise so dramatically
it has a lot to do with the prices
you're seeing here and
[Music]
here
parents are more likely to choose loves
pampers the number one pediatrician
recommended brand we're huggies we got
just what you need
it may look like there are a lot of
options to buy diapers
but in reality there are less than what
it may seem
only two companies control about eighty
percent of the us disposable diaper
industry
procter gamble and kimberly clark the
same two companies that announced price
hikes earlier this year
it means these companies are less
vulnerable to to competition
sharon turlock reports on consumer
products for the wall street journal
if png makes a decision on pricing that
might drive the whole market whether
it's up or down
they don't have the concern as much of
having higher prices and then having
their customers go somewhere else
most disposable diapers are made with
layers of blended materials to increase
absorbency
including this fluffy part which is made
from wood pulp
just a few months ago lumber prices were
through the roof
powered by low mortgage rates and demand
for home improvement projects that drove
a suburban building boom
this lifted the price of wood including
pulp which in turn drove up costs for
diaper manufacturing
costs of logging have escalated due to
the inputs
at that stage in the value chain namely
the
labor and the logistics and the
equipment associated with
felling trees david garfield is a
consultant who has worked in the
consumer products industry for almost
three decades
and those increases and costs do ripple
through
the production of pulp and paper but one
of the biggest commodities driving the
price of diapers
is the same one that is running your car
oil prices soaring an opec fueled rally
sending crude prices higher
now up about 20 just over the last month
as prices have risen at the pump
so have cost to produce diapers some of
those ingredients or materials that are
incorporated into diapers are derived
from
petroleum and so with the increase in
the price of
the barrel of oil comes an increase in
the
material that goes into making diapers
there's also the knock-on effect of
diesel fuel prices up which
impact the transportation costs as well
as the material costs
petroleum or crude oil is the same raw
material used to make sodium
polyacrylate
this is a polymer that's used in diapers
to help make them more absorbent
it's what these absorption beads are
made out of back in february a winter
storm pummeled texas
forcing many petrochemical manufacturing
plants to shut down
including those that make acrylic acid a
compound in sodium polyacrylate
the extreme weather caused acrylic acid
shortages for months
which drove up the price of sodium
polyacrylate this contributed to the
rising costs of diapers
part of it was this piling on effect it
was just one more thing on top of
everything else but it made this
material harder to come by and so
you know at the time when when i spoke
to kimberly clark they said you know
we're not
it's not driving a shortage but it's
certainly
limiting options but it wasn't just
limited access to raw materials that
have driven up
diaper prices throughout the pandemic
ongoing shipping issues due to surging
online orders
coveted restrictions and driver
shortages have caused significant delays
across the us
this has impacted deliveries across
industries including diapers
which has caused freight costs to
balloon you
have the trucking rates the labor for
drivers
the equipment that needs to be
maintained and replaced even the
insurance costs
so producers are seeing significant
increases recently in overall
transportation costs
diapers unlike some other smaller
personal care items are impacted more by
shipping costs due to the product's
bulky size
the vast majority of diaper production
in the us
is local there's a very very small
percentage
that is imported uh it's it's a highly
what they call volumetric
product meaning that per dollar of
sales it's expensive to ship and so
it's largely trucking transportation
within the u.s
from the factories to distribution
centers and ultimately through
retail channel partners still there's
one other factor affecting the
price of diapers that has been trending
for years
in the u.s births have been steadily
dropping for the past decade
the number of babies born in 2020
dropped by four percent compared with
the previous year
partially driven by a trend of women
choosing to have fewer children
later in life as the birth rate declines
it has an
instant effect on diaper sales because
babies
need diapers the minute they're born so
you know if there's fewer babies born
it's not like some products where 10
years down the road a smaller
you know smaller population might
trickle down it's you know fewer babies
are born in 2020
diaper sales go down in 2020. to make up
for lower diaper sales
companies have increased prices to
partially fill the gap
to offset this declining birth rate the
companies are trying to
basically sell more expensive diapers
that are nicer diapers so that
competition has become more
intense i mean there's you know more
organic diapers
you know there's a lot of features in
diapers now that didn't exist 10 years
ago
as diaper prices have increased for many
working families the financial strain
has added to a list of growing expenses
the need in 2021 is
seems to be almost as high or higher as
it was in 2020 so even as the economy is
recovering it's not going back to 2019
levels
experts like david garfield say that
even if commodity and shipping costs
come back down
because of increased margins diaper
price increases will likely stay
inflated for the near future